welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul welcome to the heavy
spoilers show I'm your host Paul he
sounds like there's an echo in here he
you having that and today we're going to
be breaking down the new Marvel series
created under the banner Marvel
Spotlight this was something that the
company also used to do in the comics to
try outside characters in their own
leading titles it kind of feels like
that's what's happened with Ekko as well
as she's never really been a massive
name in The Source material I must admit
I was very surprised she got her own
show then there were rumors that a
series was a complete disaster lots of
things circulated around it in the
buildup to its release and firstly
Marvel reportedly cut out an entire
episode dropping it down to five they
also announced it was going to be
released day one and lastly weren't
going to be allowing reviews until it
was officially out yeah it's been a
weird one in the buildup to the project
however people had hope when they saw
they were going for a mature audience
and featuring both their deving Kingpin
has it worked is the MCU alive is the
MCU dead or whatever state the Shing as
franchises in that week do we finally
know well it's complicated but fear not
my young Padawan for throughout this
video we're going to be going through
the series and giving our thoughts on it
this also be covering the Easter eggs
where things could be going and what we
know so far about what they're doing
with Kingpin heavy spoilers ahead and if
you don't want to know then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into echo echo ech I did
that joke before and it was the
first time I see everything that you
are I always
[Music]
have don't be
afraid
okay so we last Saw REO during the
events of Hawkeye where she was working
for the Kingpin don't worry if you
haven't seen that though because episode
one it's like a massive 45 minute long
previously on in it we see Maya Lopez
basically going through the story of
that season in which he learns her
father was murdered by the Kingpin in
the comic she debuted back in Daredevil
issue 9 which was released during 1999
like the show her father was killed by
Kingpin who then raised her as his own
child we discovered that the PA had been
business partners but after a mistake
the man had to go go go like Victoria
Alonso
so May's dad begged fist to look after
her and she was sent out to the most
prestigious schools here we see her
learning karate and Fisk protecting her
as she gets bullied though we're getting
the Netflix shows as being Cannon I am
still kind of like hm cuz you wonder why
she was never mentioned until now
basically she's the kid you never see
cuz you're too busy off doing big
reviews of echo either way in the source
material when a dad died he left a
handprint on her face which the
character wore as a mock this was given
another two in the series well sort of
by her mother when she was killed during
a car crash in the opening of episode
one other differences include that she's
chying in the comics but here they've
changed it so she's chock toown Nation
now here's where the big differences get
a bit complicated as I feel by the time
they started planning out what to do
with their devil they'd already hit the
ground running with Hawkeye in the
comics Maya was sent to break Matt H
after being told that Daredevil killed
her dad that was in the wake of Karen
PA's death in which the character was
already at his lowest she fell in love
with Matt while not realizing his
Daredevil and studied his mov so she
could best him with ease juking it out
with Daredevil this is when he told her
the truth and that she'd been a porn in
Wilson fisk's game in the end she shot
him instead which led him coming back
blinded them both eyes the show has it
so this is just one because a deadevil
is not here that much so they don't
really have to do the blind versus blind
which is a shame cuz it was pretty cool
idea now in the series she of course saw
it was Hawkeye who as we learned had
been tipped off by Fisk May would
actually become running herself and this
happened when she showed up in New
Avengers 11 either way we go over these
tidbits in episode one and when I saw
this yeah I almost quit the show the
entire opening entry just felt like a
hatchet job that got butchered in the
edit trying to figure out how to do a
recap Hawkeye had basically been her
origin but I feel like they also wanted
this series to be newcomer friendly so
what we get is massive scenes from
Hawkeye that most people watching will
have already seen you like the MCU
you're on board you're watching Kevin
spoilers you've seen the bloody show it
completely kills the pacing and on top
of this we jump forwards and backwards
in time without any Rhyme or Reason what
you basically need to know is that
Kingpin is found out and confronted by
mea which which is when she shoots him I
genu I genuinely think I'm going to turn
this off you wait is that is that Bloody
Daredevil keep keep it on best show
ever now so Matt's entrance it's
something that really comes out of
nowhere and it gives you an idea of how
he operates in the city I loved how Maya
was just beating up people for Kingpin
and then he shut up mid scene and really
raised attention now they car makes some
m a mimic that's a bit like Taskmaster
in which you can copy someone's style
and how they move around this had
allowed her to become an excellent
ballet dancer but it also meant she
could fight your boy DD however none of
these powers are present in the show
which again just felt like one of those
changes why they didn't get why people
like the character in the first place we
even had the creative team coming out
and saying her powers in the comics were
lame and again I was like who Disney you
sure know how to hire them mate sure
know how to get those people that know
how to do good PR I don't know just
fighting someone yeah who can perfectly
mirror one of your hero's moves is
something that I think's really cool to
watch now I get it I get it yeah
Taskmaster has been gender swap so we'd
have to have two women with the exact
same skill set still though I hate it I
hate it when the creative team behind
adapting a car to come out and say how
lame it is to me you should always
respect the source material but it is
fine to make changes if you think you
can tell a different story Miss Marvel
did it for the MCU and they do with her
Origins I just wish they didn't feel a
need to act like they're better than the
comics that's eego
that's a we know best mentality that
often leads to you making all the wrong
choices now though I'm bitching about
the show a lot and I do think that
episode one is the worst MCU opening
entry we've ever had I will say Echo 2
and three they do get better this is
there going back to her roots and
leaving New York to go to her estrange
family in the comic she headed out to
France to reunite with Matt however Matt
you can't you can't bloody keep a good
guy down and she found out that he was
with someone else and during this like
what we we get at the end of episode
three we discover that Kingpin was still
alive he revealed that he still loved
her like a daughter which in the comics
made her wrestle with how she felt she
then met the chief and her father's
friend and was sent on a vision quest to
come to terms with her trauma in the end
she returned her being a dancer but was
called on by Steve Rogers to help with a
break out at the raft turned out that M
recommended her and she was tasked with
capturing the villain the Silver Samurai
this this is what led to her becoming
the Ronin who took on Japanese criminals
similar to Clinton endgame later on she
was also selected as a host for the
Phoenix force with a gaining it at one
point in the comics as for the show they
play to her lineage a lot more with us
then learning the backstory of her
ancestors now some Native American
cultures believe that people were made
of clay which was to referenc in the
what if kahori Episode at the start of
episode one we see where the people came
from and how they were beings living
inside caves when these collaps they
arrived on the surface and in the Heat
Of The Sun start to be formed I think do
you understand seriously you need to be
a neuroscientist to understand mythology
is something I've not really come across
before and all I had to really go off
was the opening monologue if you guys
know that though then drop it below as
I'm sure there's more going on here than
what we're told in the intro either way
we learn that the descendants of the
leader chaffa have been blessed with
amazing gifts that run through the
family on the maternal side this has
helped them to win sports games hit the
thumbs up button and also be part of a
group known as the light Horsemen these
pulled from the story Phoenix song Echo
issue 3 which was released during 2021
this also featured the black crow which
the skat ring could be after which might
be a reach but it's just worth including
these Powers enable them in times of
great anger or extreme stress and they
also get flashbacks of all of their
ancestors it's all connected and if you
want to support the channel and check
out our all connected shirts right below
the video these will get you laid pro
pro I don't know hasn't doesn't work for
me yet but it might work for you so if
it does please let me know and I can put
that on the can put that as a selling
point on the shirt anyway at home my
reconnect with their family throughout
the course of the season this includes
chuler Scully Bonnie Henry and also your
boy you know your boy biscuit he's kind
of yeah down on his character who's
barely scraping by and these characters
help to add something more to the show
than just Echo walking around scowling
at everyone biscuit at one point brings
up mad reper which we of course saw in
Falcon in the winter Soldier this
fictional local is a Haven for criminals
and it's of course where Sharon Carter
also became the power broker I kind of
feel like we get some nods to the snap
as at one point we also find out that
he's selling a PS4 everybody's lost 5
years so hey they've got some games to
catch up on before they hit the PS5
which due to the time delay might not
have even been developed yet now they do
the usual white tourists just get the
stereotypical tourist stuff and will buy
anything that that looks like it's
Native American but to be fair those
neck ties look quite good and when you
look that snazzy mate who can bloody
blame you at the midpoint she then gets
held hostage with her family pulled into
it and also has to face off against a
man named Zane leading the black knife
cartel this is a gang that comes from
the comics who supplied every criminal
organization within the US the fight
scenes are what you'd expect and there's
bits of humors like the make America
skate again thing I'm sure they also
have the guy who plays Malik who is in
Agents of Shield but a who knows if that
is or isn't Cannon anymore I know it's
not canon mate but let me dream either
way the hits called off with a ringtone
New York Minute by Don Henley playing
out and the lyrics to that are him in a
New York minute oo everything can change
in a New York minute it can get pretty
strange now strangely the hits called
off with her being wanted dead and then
Spar showing how quickly things can
change still H what we're really
wrestling with here is someone who's
torn between two cultures and two
families in the two sites at home she
has a native Ro and lineage in a family
that love her whereas the other side is
King Pins New York here he had a train
and used as an assassin but it's of
course what she knows and where she
feels pull to I think Vincent in offo
really steals the show and every scene
he's in is a big moment in the series I
will'll talk about what they're doing
with them later on but this one takes us
into the final two episodes do get
there here we importantly really see how
Kingpin took care of Maya this was
controlling violent and represented of
the life she'd returned to if she went
back to New York the final two entries
are very much about her Breaking Free of
his control and finally embracing the
family her father took her away from we
saw that she lived a lavish lifestyle of
luxury and was truly taken care of but
this was kept through violence and fear
I think it's also important to bear in
mind the line about Kingpin not learning
sign language and he even had Tech
created so he didn't have to on the
opposite side of this her real family
have and I feel like this has a deeper
layer kind of shows how he once might
have fit into what he views how things
should be raas her family accept her for
how she is both have Dennis in the final
two entries and it's clear where she
feels the most comfortable she used to
see his actions as being heroic but then
she realized its weakness and being
unable to lead people naturally offer
the chance to be Queen pin she ends up
getting flashes of her lineage J and
also sees the bird in it hearkening back
to chaffer this has some big moments at
the start and end of episode 5 and it
helps to Showcase her mother's healing
abilities this bird is also what youa
Witnesses just before the crash in
Native American astrology woodpeckers
are often thought to represent the H of
Nature and this is to the red spots that
you can see on their heads this tapping
away against a tree has been perceived
to be like a beating heart hence why
it's adopted this Monica on top of this
though the website astrof framers stated
that the Woodpecker as a symbol is seen
as a protector of its people it's
someone that will always look after its
own which again ties in with Maya and
how the ancestors powers activate in
times of need now she gets helped by
Chula and learns of her past and how her
lineage was supposed to make her a
Healer this is of course in opposite to
FK who will use her powers for death and
destruction either way Eko goes off to
meet him and we watches Chula puts
together her costume this pulls heavily
from her Heritage with it being a
Warrior's Native American dress in
episode one she also looks at her
mother's dress which somewhat access and
inspiration for how they go with this we
got this leaked earlier in the month and
to be honest I don't know if I'm feeling
it that much I know it's leaning into
her past but I really like the get up
that they had in the comics and even the
one in Hawkeye I thought was pretty
solid this just seems like a made for TV
thing which to be fair it is however
there was concept art shown for Hawkeye
that I think would have worked a lot
better this was obviously leaked years
and years and years ago but if you
compare to the comics I think it just
stands out more either way there's
clearly influenced from the DOR malage
and it and they apparently looked at
dress from the time to influence how to
handle the aesthetic sh Rock a Go played
at leg play after it gets beaten up in
episode two which Scully makes for her
taking her closer to her family over the
New York stuff either way let me know
below mate and I know I get some people
might be annoyed at me going off at
something like this cuz you have a
strong attachment to this stuff due to
things that have happened in your life
look I get it and and every time someone
says Captain Carter is I'm ready to
done some night armor and defend the
Queen of England so if you like it yeah
let me know below and make sure you push
up that engagement come on and with Fisk
she's given the hammer that killed her
father and the opportunity to kill him
she refuses to though and in five we see
her driving out to a gas station this
has the name roxson on it which is a
company that's appeared in the
background of stuff throughout the MCU
in the comics it's an oil company that's
an evil Corporation and it was a pretty
cool Easter egg to see dropped in here
seeing a vision of her mother we then
get the reason for the change in her
powers with a character still being
called Echo this is because her lineage
Echoes to her and gives her abilities
that they all possessed strategy cunning
love it's all got to this point and it's
here that she then duns her costume this
is when we get a big Showdown with f and
you can see that he's Dunning a gray
suit I was wondering if this had
symbolic meaning to it as in the past
he's either War black or white gray is
obviously between the two and it could
showcase how he now operates he did
something similar with Luke in Star Wars
and now he's ready to act in Shades of
Gray and become something else we will
get into that but after she's here the
ancestors Awakening her and also her
family sending Fisk into a Vision World
he hears as his father beats his mother
and watches a wall in front of him
crumbles this wall is something that was
established in the Netflix series and
it's what he became focused on to help
out the pain this is why he bought
an a piece like it from Vanessa and
looked at it when he went into prison
this leaves him completely weakened
mentally and he drives off wondering
what she's done unfortunately I thought
the fight felt a bit flat and I think
this stuff it's always always going to
get compared to how it was in the
Netflix shows that was of course famous
for the long hallway fights that really
helped to Salam as being serious gry
shows tonally the grittiness that gritty
word again that keeps popping up that
doesn't feel at that level either so we
have something here that I I just felt
paled in comparison I thought we would
do something at the end to show why it
had earned its mature rating but now I'm
more convinced it was purely just a
marketing gimmick mature stuff should be
reserve of things like Peacemaker and
the boys where they go all out with
things and this wasn't anything I hadn't
seen in moonnight or secret invasion in
the end we watches she returns home and
finally Embraces her family after this
in the post credit scene we get a tease
towards FIS mayoral campaign which is
something we'd heard been in the plans
for a while last night Daniel rpk
actually dropped some leaks and talked
about how the ending of Eko had been
changed originally she was going to be
going to New York and starting up a
private investigator as with her getting
a visit from Matt about how things were
going to go apparently though they
didn't want to lock her in but I do
think she deserved deserves to be
whatever storyline that they end up
heading in Daniel said that they changed
it to make it more mayoral focused which
in the end is pretty much what we get
this is something that happened in the
comics and it went down when he found
himself trapped in Manhattan this was
during a Hydra attack and it sealed off
the island from the rest of the US
giving what he could this endeared
people to him and he used this as a way
to help his political goals one of his
big promises was that he was going to
tackle the Vigilantes and in the end
this started a street War I'd loved if
we saw him hiring and getting someone
like Bullseye back in the running as we
know from season 3 that he did end up
Surviving it's also possible this could
lead into him trying to become president
which I think would be a really cool way
to take things we know what's happened
to the one from Secret Invasion and
Harrison Ford will be playing president
Ross if he's revealed to be the Red Hulk
though that could open up the White
House and make it so that FIS could jump
into the hot seat who knows we might
even get liuk cage also running for me
and all this could lead into Devil's
Reign which I think in in the end would
be a sick way to take things but there's
still a window of opportunity that's
what the poll is telling us it could be
anybody's race now going forward we
actually have a pretty fair idea where
things are going to go in the future of
the MCU deadevil born again is
apparently releasing next year but as we
know it's been dogged by issues Marvel
is having a big overhaul at the moment
and we know that Daredevil's been a
complete disaster the studios pretty
much re shooting the show from the
ground up with them only keeping a
certain select number of scenes from
what's being created so far that is
absolutely insane and it's probably cost
them a lot to shoot it and then just
scrap it about what it's likely going to
do is set up Kingpin as an even bigger
bad and the recent interviews about him
have elevated his position now described
as a street level Thanos I think that
lots of the heroes will be working
together to take him down the Ultimate
Spider-Man 3 Omnibus that released last
month and rereading it I remembered how
much in the early u0s they had a big
buildup to him being taken down they saw
the formation of a group with Spidey
dead Heil Doctor Strange moonight shongi
and Ein fist tackling him Ein fist's
daughter had been kidnapped by him and
he ended up betraying the group with
Spidey being unmasked at this point in
time Fisk owned the rights to Spider-Man
though so he didn't want him dare due to
all the money he was making potentially
they could take him in that direction
for the MCU as at the moment no one
knows who Spider-Man is including me
which I'm sure I did but I I can't
remember who and I've just forgot most
of the characters in the group though
are already established as well so they
could easily lead into a story just like
this and now we're going to see ironfist
again but someone like K Bishop could
easily take his place I think Doctor
Strange is probably too powerful right
now to be drafted in as well cuz yeah
man would wipe him out and wipe his
sauce with him but the rest would
probably quite easily go into it now I
do think they mishandled Hawaiian
Kingpin in Hawkeye and I don't know if
it was smart starting him off by having
Kate Bishop beat him and then Echo shoot
him in the same episode they did
something similar with Kang where it's
difficult to feel he's a threat where he
gets beaten badly every time he appears
still what Marvel have is the Legacy
left behind by the Netflix shows which
are doing a lot of the heavy lifting on
this and no doubt down the line there
are rumors that Daredevil's going to be
showing up in Spider-Man 4 so that would
be a pretty cool way to connect them all
and have them go toe to- Toe with him
I'd love to see someone like Jessica
Jones and Luke Cage arrived too and they
could definitely have Fisk as this big
villain that unites all the TV
characters they could then face off
against him in a film which is something
they seem to be doing with thrown in
Star Wars and the shows and yeah it
would be nice to have these shows feel
consequential rather than what they have
now outside of Loki that takes me into
my thoughts in the series and I think
you can probably guess what what they
are based on what I've said so far the
series is up there for me is just being
another mid MCU show that makes me lose
faith in their Disney plus outings what
if and Loki was stuff I really love but
on the whole now I just going expecting
stuff to be me and I'm actually
surprised when it's good that shouldn't
be the case and you can tell they didn't
have confidence in the project either
which is why they ripped the band off
and dropped them all in one day they've
delayed a number of their films to next
year now and we're only getting Deadpool
on the big screen IR heart filmed in
November 2022 and won't get released
until November 2025 and yeah deadevil is
being completely reworked Captain
America 4 is going through four months
of re-shoot and I think the studio know
that they could be in trouble feel like
the MCU it used to have a direction and
as an audience I felt we were all on
this ride together however this just
feels directional and more of a vle for
Kingpin than anyone else in it it's a
shame as there are the odd flashes of
good things but from the off it's like
it's being completely hacked to nothing
the first episode yeah the editing is
all over the place and it just kills
things with the random time jumps and
nonsensical flashbacks you also have the
power origin stuff which when viewed on
its own can be pretty good however when
we barely know our main character and
aren't we tell what's going on having
these random jumps back hundreds and
thousands of years makes it difficult to
connect with the series I can imagine
that having a de character as your lead
you know it it's going to be difficult
to figure out how to present that as
you're going to be relying heavily on
subtitles and also people reading that's
fair enough but then to add flashbacks
that are all subtitled or to put put a
silent movie in where you have to read I
wonder if they were aware how much
they'd kill the mass of Peel of it now
look yeah I don't mind subtitles at all
and I will happily watch all the Grudge
movies back to back over the space of a
day Mass audiences though they they
don't have a reputation for liking them
and it's red as see a subtitle film get
anywhere near the box office that an
English-speaking film does so yeah we
deleted with that and I think this
series kind of speaks a lot of the
arrogance in Hollywood and Marvel right
now they think they can just make a show
and it'll be great but the people I hire
they disrespect The Source material
change everything and try to steer it
away from what made it popular in the
first place I think Marvel knew this was
coming and just try to shuffle this out
the door as quickly as possible so the
conversation about it wouldn't last for
the months it would have with a weekly
episodic release now I think the action
scenes work well in it and like I said
the Daredevil one that really popped off
for me the train stuff was good too and
there's these moments started throughout
that when I felt like the show was just
about a crash and burn this slightly
pulled it out of it we also have the
family inside characters that I think
work well to bolster it on top of that
if I'm going to be honest after Hawkeye
I wasn't that interested in Echo and I
thought that making a show based around
her was going to be a bad move this
series did make me slightly more
intrigued about her and loal Cox fits
nice into the role I can't really
imagine anyone else playing her at this
point and I think once she goes back to
the more the more gritty New York stuff
that she'll be a great character and
things like Daredevil and what they're
doing with Kingpin kind of feels like
they took an interesting side character
fleshed out their backstory in a side
series and then that'll obviously pay
off more as we get into the more major
names in the franchise so yeah long term
you know this might pay off better as we
get more attach to this character and
depending what they do with her down the
line you know that could really help her
out now I know this stuff's important
for representation and I've had backlash
for just saying I didn't like it on
Twitter if you did then maybe you saw
something in it that I didn't but I
think if Marvel really want to do
service to the people they're
representing that they need to do more
representation shouldn't just be a free
pass from criticism and they should be
aiming to make something that stands up
to other entertainment pray the cahor
episode of what if they all feel like
they really put the effort in and can
easy go toe-to-toe with other movies and
episodes alongside them here though it
just feels like they dumped it and even
cut it down to five episodes so they
could rush it out the door which I don't
think gives it a fair shake after a
rocky start with episode one though it
manages to get back on track it never
feels like it's hitting at that home run
level and thus I left Ekko disappointed
the story just isn't at a high enough
level or crafted the point that the
actors can truly sell it everyone's kind
of doing what they have with the
material but at its core there's nothing
here that really takes things beyond
that level of mediocrity honestly I hate
going off like this and I'll make way
more money when the franchise is in good
state so I'm hoping for my own wallet
Insanity that we return to that time
this ain't it though and yeah whether
you agree or disagree let me know below
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
hopefully you've enjoyed hearing my
thoughts even if you disagreed with them
and yeah try and keep it civil mate
we're not all here fighting over movie
franchises are we well probably turns
out we are but we the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
Paul I'll see you next time take care
peace